This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And this, of course, is the theme for one of the most epic training sequences of all time. It's from the 1976 movie, Rocky, and it plays as the struggling boxer in Philadelphia, Rocky Balboa, builds his strength for the big fight by doing one-arm push-ups and using a giant slab of raw meat as a punching back. The training montage ends with him bounding up the 72 steps of the Philadelphia Museum of Art. The camera's panning around him and he raises his fists up victoriously. This is producer Justin Kramer. Until I rewatched the movie recently, I'd pretty much forgotten everything else about it.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当然，这也是有史以来最具史诗感的训练序列之一的主题曲。它来自1976年的电影《洛奇》，当苦苦挣扎的费城拳击手洛奇·巴尔博亚通过做单臂俯卧撑以及把一块巨大的生肉当成沙袋来为大战积蓄力量时，这首音乐便响了起来。训练蒙太奇以他奔上费城艺术博物馆的72级台阶而告终。镜头围绕着他摇动，他胜利地举起双拳。这是制作人贾斯汀·克莱默。直到最近重温这部电影之前，关于它的其他一切我几乎都忘光了。
Like, this moment is my image of the film. Rocky jumping up and down in front of the museum, arms raised, all of Philly below him. Rocky's run up the steps becomes this iconic moment. And pretty much immediately, people who, run up the steps as part of their exercise routine in Philadelphia become associated with Rocky. And it becomes recognized as this fan practice where people are responding to the film and they're running up the steps. Laura Holesman teaches art history and museum studies at Indiana University. She's written about Rocky's legacy in Philadelphia cultural history. And in Rocky 2,
比如说，这个时刻就是我对这部电影的印象。洛奇在博物馆前上蹿下跳，双臂高举，整个费城都在他脚下。洛奇奔上台阶成为了标志性的一刻。几乎立刻，那些把奔跑上台阶作为费城日常锻炼一部分的人们，就与洛奇联系在了一起。这成了一种粉丝行为，人们用这种方式回应电影并跑上台阶。劳拉·霍尔斯曼在印第安纳大学教授艺术史和博物馆学。她写过关于洛奇在费城文化历史中的遗产的文章。而在《洛奇2》中，
the movie acknowledges the prominence of this fan practice because he repeats the run up the steps, and this time he's joined by a group of kids as he runs up the stairs. Today, at the top of those iconic steps in front of the art museum, stands an eight-and-a-half-foot tall statue of Rocky Balboa, a gift to the city of Philadelphia from the film star, Sylvester Stallone. It's a bronze sculpture, and it depicts Rocky dressed like a boxer in that same victorious stance. Standing on a one-and-a-half-foot base, this chiseled glass, this chiseled glass. Ladiator towers over the Benjamin Franklin Parkway, a stretch of Philly that's home to some of the city's most famous museums and cultural sites. That location really highlights just how important the statue is in the city.
电影承认了这种粉丝行为的突出地位，因为他重复了奔跑上台阶的动作，而这一次，当他奔跑上楼梯时，有一群孩子加入了他的行列。今天，在艺术博物馆前那些标志性台阶的顶端，矗立着一座八点五英尺高的洛奇·巴尔博亚雕像，这是电影明星西尔维斯特·史泰龙送给费城这座城市的礼物。这是一座青铜雕塑，它描绘了洛奇穿着拳击手服装、摆出同样胜利姿态的模样。这座雕像耸立在富兰克林·帕克威大道上方，俯瞰着这片费城拥有该市一些最著名博物馆和文化场所的区域。这个位置真正突显了这座雕像在这座城市中的重要性。
Around 4 million people visit the Rocky Statue every year, about the same as the Statue of Liberty. When Stallone first gave the statue to Philly, this is exactly where he wanted it to live, at the top of the museum steps, fists high, looking over the city. just like the movie. But it would be decades before this became the Rocky statue's permanent home. Because what started as a simple gesture of gratitude and possibly a bit of self-aggrandizement soon became much more. The statue set off a 50-year battle about class, public space, and what it means for a single piece of art to represent an entire city.
每年大约有400万人参观洛奇雕像，这与自由女神像的游客量差不多。当史泰龙首次将这座雕像赠予费城时，这正是他希望它摆放的地方——在博物馆台阶的顶端，双拳高举，俯瞰着这座城市，就像电影里一样。但要让这里成为洛奇雕像的永久家园，还需要几十年的时间。因为最初作为一个简单的感恩姿态、甚至可能带有少许自我吹嘘意味的东西，很快演变为了更多内容。这座雕像引发了一场长达50年的关于阶级、公共空间以及一件艺术品代表整座城市意味着什么的争论。
In the way that great boxers aren't born as indomitable fortresses of muscle, the Rocky Statue began its life, not as an important public sculpture, but a common movie prop. Ceylon had the statue built in 1980. Originally, it was for a scene in Rocky III in which a fictional mayor, standing next to the statue at the top of the museum steps, dedicates it to the city of Philadelphia. It is with tremendous honor that we present this memorial, which will stand always as a celebration to the indomitable spirit. of man. Philadelphia salutes its favorite son,
正如伟大的拳击手并非生来就是坚不可摧的肌肉堡垒一样，洛奇雕像的诞生并非作为一件重要的公共雕塑，而是一个普通的电影道具。史泰龙在1980年让人建造了这座雕像。最初，它是为了《洛奇3》中的一个场景而制作的：在这个场景中，一个虚构的市长站在博物馆台阶顶端的雕像旁边，将其献给费城这座城市。我们怀着无比的荣幸呈献这座纪念碑，它将永远作为对人类不屈不挠精神的礼赞而挺立。费城向其最喜爱的儿子致敬，
Rocky Balboa. But instead of getting the art department to make this prop out of painted plastic and foam, Stallone paid $53,000 to an artist named A. Thomas Schaumburg to cast the statue in bronze.
洛奇·巴尔博亚。但史泰龙没有让艺术部门用涂漆塑料和泡沫来制作这个道具，而是支付了53,000美元给一位名叫A·托马斯·绍姆堡的艺术家，用青铜铸造了这座雕像。
It is really significant that he chose to have this be made of fine art materials and not just stuff that would be thrown into the trash bin at the end of the film shoot. Stallone once called Rocky a, quote, euphemism for the city of Philadelphia. Some have speculated that he had always wanted the statue to be a permanent piece of public
他选择用纯艺术材料而不是仅仅在电影拍摄结束时就会被扔进垃圾桶的东西来制作它，这真的意义重大。史泰龙曾把洛奇称为，引述，费城这座城市的委婉说法。有些人推测，他一直希望这座雕像能成为当地的一件永久公共
art there. Stallone went to high school in Philly, and because of his and the statue's connection to the city, he made an offer. He said that after the Rocky 3 film shoot, he wanted to donate the 1,800-pound statue to Philadelphia to stand permanently at the top of the museum steps. But almost as soon as Stallone announced his plans, there were haters, critics who didn't want the statue anywhere near the Philadelphia Museum of Art. Some refused to indulge what they saw as just an ego trip for Stallone.
艺术品。史泰龙在费城读的高中，由于他和这座雕像与该市的联系，他提出了一项提议。他说，在《洛奇3》电影拍摄结束后，他想把这座重达1,800磅的雕像捐赠给费城，让它永久矗立在博物馆台阶的顶端。但几乎就在史泰龙宣布其计划的同时，反对者就出现了——那些不希望这座雕像出现在费城艺术博物馆附近的批评者。有些人拒绝纵容他们认为只是史泰龙个人自我膨胀的行为。
Others said it was simply an ad for his films. But the strongest opposition came from the leadership at the museum. Their beef with the statue emerged from a much larger concern. At the time, Philly's influential art patrons and tastemakers were trying to figure out how to return Philly to its former glory as a hub of national culture. Philly was hot back in the day. I mean, like, way back in the day, like 1776 back, when Philadelphia was at the center of the nation's founding. But by the early 20th century, that shine had seriously faded. Philly looked more like your typical East Coast American city.
另一些人则说它纯粹是他的电影广告。但最强烈的反对来自博物馆的领导层。他们对这座雕像的不满源于一种更大的担忧。当时，费城有影响力的艺术赞助商和风向标人物正试图弄清楚如何让费城恢复其作为全国文化中心的昔日辉煌。费城在过去曾是个热门地方。我的意思是，是很久以前，比如1776年那会儿，当时费城处于国家创立的中心。但到了20世纪初，这种光彩已经严重黯淡。费城看起来更像是一个典型的美国东海岸城市。
And by the time of the bicentennial, so 1976, Philadelphia had a reputation as a city that just couldn't get a break. There was a crumbling urban infrastructure. There was a lot of corruption in local politics. In the nostalgia stirred up by that bicentennial, the 1980s art crowd were dreaming of ways to remake Phil. as a grand cultural metropolis. They aspired for the city to again become,
到了美国建国二百周年之际，也就是1976年，费城赢得了这样一种声誉：它是一座怎么也走不出困境的城市。这里有着日趋衰败的城市基础设施。地方政治中存在着大量腐败。在建国二百周年所激起的怀旧情绪中，20世纪80年代的艺术界人士正梦想着重塑费城，将其打造为一个宏伟的文化大都市。他们渴望这座城市能够再次成为，
as a famous architect once called it, the Athens of the Western world, a city that would boast one of the nation's premier art scenes. This art crowd had invested a lot in the city's preeminent museum. And they didn't think this nine-foot-tall boxer with shredded abs was going to push Philly toward that dream. They were inclined to tell Stallone, thanks for the gift, but we will decide where it goes.
正如一位著名建筑师曾经称呼的那样，西方世界的雅典，一座拥有全国顶尖艺术场景之一的城市。这个艺术界群体在城市最卓越的博物馆上投入了大量资金。他们并不认为这个拥有健美腹肌的九英尺高拳击手会推动费城朝着那个梦想前进。他们倾向于对史泰龙说，谢谢你的礼物，但我们将决定它去哪里。
By the way, it won't be anywhere near the museum. But that wasn't actually up to the museum. Instead, that decision fell to a couple of city commissions, which voted on the selection and placement of public art around the museum. One of those agencies was an eight-member group simply called the Art Commission. And before they even met to place their votes on where the statue could live, things weren't looking good for Rocky. The president of the commission was a wealthy art patron,
顺便说一句，它绝对不会靠近博物馆。但事实上这并不是由博物馆说了算。相反，这一决定落在了几个市级委员会身上，这些委员会对博物馆周围公共艺术的选择和摆放进行投票表决。其中一个机构是一个由八名成员组成、简称为艺术委员会的团体。甚至在他们开会投票决定雕像可以安家何处之前，事情对洛奇来说就不太妙。该委员会的主席是一位富有的艺术赞助人，
named F. Eugene Dixon, Jr. His friends called him Fitz. He'd invested a lot of money in Philly's art sector. And when he got word of Stallone's gift, he said it would be fine for the statute to stand temporarily on the steps while Stallone promoted Rocky Three. But in a letter to a colleague, he added, If, however, this statue is to be placed somewhere in the courtyard
名叫小F·尤金·迪克森。他的朋友们叫他菲茨。他在费城的艺术领域投入了大量资金。当他得知史泰龙的礼物时，他说，在史泰龙宣传《洛奇3》期间，让这座雕像临时立在台阶上是可以的。但在写给一位同事的信中，他补充道：“然而，如果这座雕像要被永久安放在庭院的某个地方，
on a permanent basis, I hope you are adjusting. That's not Fitz. That's right. Mark Bowden. He's tying the letter with best regards, as always, sincerely yours, fits. I just picture him in his mahogany-lined library out on the farm in Montgomery County. I'm just, like, who are they kidding? Mark is the author of numerous acclaimed and best-selling books, including Black Hawk Down and Killing Pablo. At the time, he was a staff writer for the Philadelphia Inquirer's Sunday magazine, and he covered the Rocky Statue Gift. I was intrigued by the
我希望你有所调整。”那不是菲茨。没谱。马克·博登。他用“致以最诚挚的问候，一如既往，您的真诚的菲茨”来结束这封信。我只是想象着他在蒙哥马利县农场那间镶着红木的书房里的样子。我当时想，他们是在跟谁开玩笑呢？马克是众多广受好评和畅销的书籍的作者，其中包括《黑鹰坠落》和《杀死巴勃罗》。当时，他是《费城问询报》周日杂志的专栏作家，并报道了洛奇雕像的礼物事件。我对
sort of collision between what's popular and what's regarded as serious art. As Mark worked on the story, he discovered the museum crowd bristled even at the use of the term art when discussing the Rocky Statue. Their position? We're not even talking about really a work of art. We're talking about a movie prop. This raised a question for me. As art goes, could one deign to call the Rocky Statue an aesthetically good sculpture? Like, was it beautifully crafted? How did it stack up pound for pound against other famous sculptures. I brought my questions to Laura Halsman. Is it a good statue?
流行事物与被视为严肃艺术的事物之间的某种碰撞很感兴趣。当马克着手撰写这个故事时，他发现博物馆的人群甚至对在讨论洛奇雕像时使用“艺术”这个词都感到恼火。他们的立场是：我们甚至不是在讨论真正的一件艺术品。我们讨论的是一个电影道具。这给我提出了一个问题。就艺术而言，人们能否屈尊将洛奇雕像称为一件美学上优秀的雕塑？比如，它的工艺精湛吗？它在同等重量的对比下，与其它著名雕塑相比如何？我把我的问题带给了劳拉·霍尔斯曼。它是一尊好雕塑吗？
That's such a hard question to answer. What makes anything a good statue? She did her best to avoid it. I can say that it means something very important to a lot of people. Went to great lengths to preface her answer. I mean no offense to the people who worked really, really hard to produce it, maintain it, install it. Then ultimately gave in.
这是一个如此难以回答的问题。是什么让任何东西成为一尊好雕塑？她尽力避而不谈。“我可以说，它对很多人来说有着非常重要的意义。”她费尽心思为自己的回答做铺垫。“我对那些为制作、维护、安装它而付出非常非常多努力的人没有丝毫恶意。”然后最终妥协了。
Yeah, okay, I will say, on aesthetic terms, the Rocky statue doesn't quite do it for me. He's kind of awkward looking. Other art historians and critics I spoke to weren't so diplomatic. One called it, quote, a pretty limp piece of sculpture, not a powerful work of art,
“好吧，我会说，从美学角度来看，洛奇雕像对我的胃口还差了点。他的外表有点尴尬。”我采访过的其他艺术史学家和批评家就没有那么外交辞令了。其中一人称其为，引述，一件相当苍白的雕塑作品，算不上强有力的艺术品，
and a very superficial look at the human body. Another praised Rocky's armpit hair to the exclusion of every other detail in the statue. So it's not surprising that in the winter of 1980, the Art Commission voted six to two to reject the permanent placement of the statue on the museum steps. Sloan could put it there to film his movie, but after Rocky Three wrapped,
而且对人体的观察非常肤浅。另一个人则称赞洛奇的腋毛，排除了雕像中的所有其他细节。因此，1980年冬天，艺术委员会以六票对两票投票否决了将该雕像永久安放在博物馆台阶上的方案，这并不令人意外。史泰龙可以把它放在那里拍摄他的电影，但在《洛奇3》杀青之后，
the commission would choose a different place to park his gift to the city. And if you're wondering, the remaining two votes were to bar the statue from the steps entirely. So the statue stood for a few days at the top of the museum steps while they filmed Rocky 3. Then it was packed up and shipped all the way to L.A., where some might say, a movie prop belongs. But the fight was far from over, because while some wealthy influential art patrons, some might call snobs, did not appreciate the statue, a lot of other Philadelphians did. To them, the idea of a local guy who fought his way to the top through pure grit and determination, no trust fund needed,
委员会将选择一个不同的地方来放置他送给这座城市的礼物。如果你在好奇的话，另外两票是主张完全禁止该雕像出现在台阶上。因此，在拍摄《洛奇3》的那几天里，雕像一直矗立在博物馆台阶的顶端。然后它被打包运回了洛杉矶——有些人可能会说，这才是电影道具该去的地方。但这场争端远未结束，因为虽然一些富有且有影响力的艺术赞助人——有些人可能会称之为势利小人——并不欣赏这座雕像，但许多其他费城人却很欣赏。对他们来说，一个当地小伙子通过纯粹的毅力和决心一路拼搏到顶峰、不需要任何信托基金的概念，
this was the real Philadelphia, working class Philadelphia. So at the same time Stallone's team was pressing the city to put the statue back in Philly, a similar push came from a local truck driver named Art Gorman. He was one of the statue's biggest champions. Here's Mark Bowden again. Art, you know, was just a huge enthusiast of the movie Rocky and hence Sylvester Stallone. He is a sort of assault of the earth, Philly, guy from a blue-collar neighborhood who feels like who are these snooty guardians of good taste
这就是真正的费城，工人阶级的费城。因此，就在史泰龙的团队敦促市政府把雕像搬回费城的同时，一位名叫阿特·戈尔曼的当地卡车司机也发起了类似的呼吁。他是这座雕像的坚定支持者之一。再次请出马克·博登。你知道的，阿特只是电影《洛奇》以及因此而来的西尔维斯特·史泰龙的超级狂热爱好者。他是一个朴实无华、来自蓝领社区的费城人，他觉得这些自命不凡、自诩品味高雅的守护者算什么，
to be telling us what we should be able to see on the steps of the Philadelphia Art Museum. We want it there. In late 1980, Gorman drafted a petition in support of bringing the statue from L.A. back to Philly permanently. I do think we should note it was written entirely in capital letters. Mark read me some of the petition. Rocky statues should be back in Philly, remember? Rocky won. When you and the kids went to the movie, what did they and yourself feel? Seeing Philly on the screen instead of New York or San Francisco,
凭什么对我们能在费城艺术博物馆的台阶上看到什么指手画脚。我们就要它在那里。1980年底，戈尔曼起草了一份请愿书，支持将雕像从洛杉矶永久带回费城。我认为我们确实应该注意到，它是完全用大写字母写的。马克向我宣读了部分请愿书。“洛奇雕像应该回到费城，还记得吗？洛奇赢了。当你和孩子们去看电影时，他们和你自己有什么感受？在大银幕上看到费城而不是纽约或旧金山，
pretty good, ha! Why don't you voice your opinion if you feel that the statue should be back in Philly? Gorman hit the streets, collecting thousands of signatures from regular Philadelphians. This impassioned 33-year-old, door-knocking around Philly, fighting to bring back to the the Rocky statue, drummed up a bunch of media coverage. Petitions are being collected around Philadelphia asking for the return of Rocky. It seems like the story gets told in a way that pits blue-collar Philadelphia against elitist high culture Philadelphia, this narrative of, you know, slabs versus snobs. Still, it was the snobs who got to vote on the matter, and the petition didn't change their basic stance.
感觉相当不错，哈！如果你觉得雕像应该回到费城，为什么不表达你的意见呢？”戈尔曼走上街头，从普通费城人那里收集了数千个签名。这位充满激情、四处奔走为带回洛奇雕像而战的33岁年轻人，引起了大量媒体的报道。“费城各地正在收集请愿书，要求让洛奇回归。”这个故事的讲述方式似乎将蓝领费城与精英高雅文化费城对立起来，这就是所谓的粗俗与势利之争的叙事。尽管如此，拥有投票权的是那些势利小人，而请愿书并没有改变他们基本的立场。
Rocky 3 was about to come out in theaters, so the art commission said, fine, the statue could come back to the museum steps, but only for the premiere. As soon as that was over, Stallone's gift would have to be taken off the stairs. Rocky 3 opened in May 1982. Philly's celebration featuring the Rocky statue came and went. But the production company kind of just left it there, and the city won't pay to have it removed. So the museum has to take care of it. It was several months before movers finally came to haul the statue away. But when they got to the museum, they had one more obstacle to deal with.
《洛奇3》即将在影院上映，所以艺术委员会说，好吧，雕像可以回到博物馆台阶，但仅限于首映期间。一旦那结束了，史泰龙的礼物就必须从台阶上撤走。《洛奇3》于1982年5月上映。费城以洛奇雕像为特色的庆祝活动来去匆匆。但制作公司基本上就把它留在了那里，而市政府又不愿花钱将其移除。所以博物馆不得不负责照看它。几个月后，搬运工才终于来把雕像运走。但当他们到达博物馆时，他们还要面对另一个障碍。
The statue was bolted to the pavement with steel rods that went several feet into the ground. It was as if the movie producers meant for it to stay there forever. But the statue was finally pried loose and hauled five miles away to its new home in South Philly at the Spectrum Sports Arena where other statues of athletes stood. And to most, it seemed. like the fight was over. But, you know, it's Rocky. The fight over the statue kept going, partly because the movie franchise just kept going. Yep, big reveal, the Rocky series did not end up being a trilogy. There was another. Rocky 4 is one of the big hits of the holiday season. And another.
这座雕像用深入地下好几英尺的钢筋螺栓固定在路面上。就好像电影制片人存心让它永远留在那儿似的。但雕像最终还是被撬松，并被运到五英里外位于南费城的南费城体育馆——那里还矗立着其他运动员的雕像。对大多数人来说，这似乎标志着斗争的结束。但是，你知道的，这是洛奇。围绕这座雕像的斗争仍在继续，部分原因在于电影系列一直在拍下去。是的，重大揭秘，《洛奇系列》最终并没有成为三部曲。还有续集。《洛奇4》是假日季的大热门之一。还有更多。
The Rocky production crew spent two months in Philadelphia filming Rocky 5. As he cranked out sequels, Stallone asked the Art Commission, repeatedly to move the statue from the spectrum to the museum for good. And each time, the commission said no. And that's how it went for 25 years. Rocky punched, the museum counterpunched. Then in 2006, Rocky got his best opportunity yet. John Street, Philly's mayor at the time,
《洛奇》制作团队在费城花了两个月时间拍摄《洛奇5》。随着他不断拍出续集，史泰龙一再要求艺术委员会将雕像从体育馆永久移至博物馆。每一次，委员会都说不。事情就这样持续了25年。洛奇出拳，博物馆进行反击。然后在2006年，洛奇迎来了迄今为止最好的机会。时任费城市长约翰·斯特里特，
had launched several projects to revitalize public spaces all over the city. So the topic of what public art would be displayed in those spaces had some traction. Meanwhile, Stallone was preparing to release Rocky Balboa, the first Rocky movie in 16 years. Philly usually hosted big Rocky premier parties, which helped promote the
启动了几个旨在复兴全市公共空间的工程。因此，这些空间应该展示什么公共艺术这一话题获得了一些关注。与此同时，史泰龙正准备发行16年来的第一部《洛奇》电影《洛奇·巴尔博亚》。费城通常会举办盛大的《洛奇》首映派对，这有助于宣传
movies and the city. At that point, the Rocky statue was in storage while the city built a new sports complex. This seemed like the perfect moment for it to reemerge as a piece of public art and to use it to celebrate the new film. That's when a lawyer named Jimmy Benz
电影和这座城市。当时，当城市建造新的体育综合体时，洛奇雕像正被存放在仓库里。这似乎是它作为一件公共艺术品重新出现、并利用它来庆祝新电影的绝佳时机。就在那时，一位名叫吉米·本茨的律师
decided to make a very important phone call. Jimmy was a friend of Sylvester Stallone. He appeared in one of the Rocky sequels and had a reputation as a Philly power broker. I got Jimmy on the phone and he told me how he asked Stallone if he wanted some help getting the statue to the museum. Stallone said, yeah. So Jimmy called up the mayor and told him that he, Jimmy, would like the statue back at the museum. Here's what he said. He said, you know, those people go crazy. Those people meaning the trustees of the museum. And I said to him, well, let me ask you a question. I said, do those people invite you over to their house on Sunday afternoon for cocktails?
决定打一个非常重要的电话。吉米是西尔维斯特·史泰龙的朋友。他曾在其中一部《洛奇》续集中出镜，在费城政商两界有着很大的影响力。我给吉米打了电话，他告诉我他是如何问史泰龙是否需要帮助把雕像弄到博物馆的。史泰龙说，好啊。于是吉米打电话给市长，告诉他，他——也就是吉米——想要把雕像弄回博物馆。他是这么说的。他说：“你知道，那些人会疯掉的。”“那些人”指的是博物馆的董事。然后我对他说，“好吧，让我问你一个问题，”我说，“那些人星期天下午有没有邀请你去他们家喝鸡尾酒？”
And he laughed and he said, no. And I said, well, fuck them. And he said, okay, fuck him. With the mayor's support, the idea of placing the statue at the museum finally started gaining real momentum. Even the Philadelphia Museum of Art began to bend. The mayor's office was able to persuade the museum to consider Stallone's vision. The museum in the mayor's office began to hash out a potential compromise. The statue would move out of storage and back to the museum permanently.
他笑了，然后说，没有。我说，好吧，那管他妈的。他说，好吧，管他妈的。在市长的支持下，将雕像放置在博物馆的构想终于开始获得真正的势头。甚至费城艺术博物馆也开始妥协。市长办公室成功说服博物馆考虑史泰龙的愿景。博物馆和市长办公室开始敲定一个潜在的妥协方案。雕像将从仓库搬出，并永久返回博物馆。
However, not at the top of the steps, but at the bottom and a little to the side. At long last, after nearly a quarter century of petitioning, it seemed like Stallone was about to make his dream come true. The only hurdle left was the Art Commission, because they were the ones who still had the final vote on, where the statue would go. When this fight started, they were the statue haters. But this time, it seemed like they might play ball. So in May of 2006, the Philadelphia Art Commission announces that the statue might be relocated to the museum. And a whole additional wave of public debate comes out of that.
然而，不是在台阶顶端，而是在底部并稍微靠边一点。经过近四分之一世纪的请愿，经历了这么久，史泰龙的梦想似乎终于要成真了。唯一剩下的障碍是艺术委员会，因为他们仍然对雕像的去向拥有最终投票权。当这场争端开始时，他们是雕像的死敌。但这一次，他们似乎愿意配合了。因此，在2006年5月，费城艺术委员会宣布雕像可能会被重新安置到博物馆。由此引发了又一轮的公众辩论。
That debate involved not just commission members, but all sorts of gatekeepers who were weighing in on the statue's artistic merit. And where to put it? One city official named Harris Baum went on a local NPR Collins show to express his desire to keep the statue far away from the museum. He said it clashed with the commission's grand vision for the Benjamin Franklin Parkway where the museum sits. We're trying to develop the parkway to become a Shumseille, similar to what they have in Paris. And we want to develop more art around the art museum as such. but that is not a piece of art. But the response Baum got wasn't the same as it might have been back in the 1980s.
这场辩论不仅涉及委员会成员，还包括对雕像的艺术价值发表意见的各类把关人。以及把它放在哪里？一位名叫哈里斯·鲍姆的市政府官员在当地NPR电台的连线节目中表达了他希望将雕像远离博物馆的愿望。他说，这与委员会对博物馆所在的富兰克林·帕克威大道的宏伟构想相冲突。“我们正试图将帕克威大道开发成香榭丽舍大道，类似于他们在巴黎所拥有的那样。并且我们希望在艺术博物馆周围开发更多这样的艺术。但那不是一件艺术品。”但鲍姆得到的反应已经不像80年代那样了。
Now, listeners didn't want to get pulled into a debate about art. Baum was fighting an old fight. For the listeners who called in, it was about how Rocky represented them. Hi, Judy, go ahead, your radio times. You can put me at the top of the steps camp. That statue is an icon. It's an image of the blue collar spirit of our town. It illustrates what we are all about in Philadelphia.
现在，听众们不想被卷入关于艺术的争论。鲍姆是在进行一场过时的斗争。对于打进电话的听众来说，关键在于洛奇代表了他们。“嗨，朱迪，请讲，这里是广播时间。”“你可以把我归入支持台阶顶端的那一派。那座雕像是个图腾。它是我们城镇蓝领精神的象征。它说明了我们在费城所代表的一切。”
Let me get Jack from Lansdale to join us. Hi, Jack, go ahead. You're on the air. I just want to say ideally I'd like to see the top of the steps, but a bunch of pompous powdered wigs aren't going to let that happen. Well, just one quick question. I mean, are you calling Harris Bomb Pompus? Yeah, absolutely.
让兰斯代尔的杰克加入我们。嗨，杰克，请讲，你在直播。“我只想说，理想情况下我想看到它在台阶顶端，但一群自命不凡、头戴假发的人是不会让这种事发生的。”“好吧，我只想问个问题。我的意思是，你是在叫哈里斯·鲍姆自命不凡吗？”“对，绝对是的。”
The snobbery that he was that he's exuding earlier, it's just, it's insulting. Pardon me, sir, but maybe Philadelphia likes it where it is. Why do you get to decide what Philadelphia looks like? You can hear it. Philadelphia's had developed a loyalty to the statue. It's like they were defending a guy from their own neighborhood. On September 6, 2006, the Art Commission voted again on whether or not the Rocky statue could finally live beside the museum steps. And the minutes from that meeting reflect a clear shift in their thinking.
他之前散发出的那种势利，简直是侮辱人。打扰一下，先生，但也许费城人就喜欢它现在待的地方。凭什么由你来决定费城应该是什么样子？你可以听得出来。费城人已经对这座雕像产生了忠诚感。就像他们在保护自己社区里的人一样。2006年9月6日，艺术委员会再次就洛奇雕像是否最终可以安家于博物馆台阶旁进行投票。该次会议的记录反映出他们的想法发生了明显的转变。
Quote, most members felt that the statue's iconic symbolism has won it a place in the city's identity. By a vote of 6 to 2, the Art Commission finally approved plans to install the Rocky Statue at the museum. The snobs had given in. Less than a week later, the city unveiled the statue in its new home at the base of the museum steps, and a little to the side. So this is a clip from KYW TV in Philly, and you hear the audience roar when the music swells and the curtain drops and an eight-and-a-half-foot bronze rocky is unveiled. Stallone walks up to the statue and kind of marvels at it in this boyish way. Like, how did this finally happen? He lifts his hand and pats the statue admiringly on its rock-hard abs.
引述，“大多数成员认为，该雕像标志性的象征意义已经为它在城市的身份认同中赢得了一席之地。”艺术委员会以6比2的投票结果，最终批准了在博物馆安装洛奇雕像的计划。势利小人们妥协了。不到一周后，这座城市在博物馆台阶底部、稍微偏侧的新家揭幕了这座雕像。所以这是费城KYW电视台的一个剪辑，你可以听到当音乐高潮迭起、幕布拉开、一尊八点半英尺高的青铜洛奇揭幕时，观众爆发出的欢呼声。史泰龙走到雕像前，以一种男孩般的方式对其啧啧称奇。仿佛在说：这到底是怎么做到的？他举起手，赞赏地拍了拍雕像那硬如磐石的腹肌。
I have to say, I found the whole thing oddly touching. I can't believe you've allowed me to come into your lives in such a way and have this incredible. This is actually mind-bending to me that this could happen. I asked Laura Halsman if she thinks this was the museum and the Art Commission finally embracing the Rocky statue after 26 years of resistance. I think it's an acceptance. By 2006, it doesn't just work as an advertisement for the Rocky movies. It works as an advertisement for Philadelphia. And Philadelphia's grit and resilience and Philadelphia's fame, not just from fine art, but also from pop culture. This acceptance marked a new era in the statue's life. What you start to see is an understanding that this is becoming a fixture in the city's landscape. It's emerging as a monument,
我必须说，我发现整件事有一种奇异的感人之处。“我简直不敢相信你们允许我以这种方式进入你们的生活，并拥有这不可思议的……”这对我来说简直太不可思议了，这种事竟然会发生。我问劳拉·霍尔斯曼，她是否认为这是博物馆和艺术委员会在经历了26年的抵抗后，最终接受了洛奇雕像。“我认为这是一种接受。到2006年，它不仅起到了《洛奇》电影广告的作用。它起到了费城广告的作用。以及费城的坚韧和不屈，以及费城的名声，不仅来自纯艺术，也来自流行文化。”这种接受标志着雕像生命中的新时代。你开始看到的一种理解是，它正在成为城市景观中的一个固定装置。它正在作为一座纪念碑崛起，
and it's being treated as that. Paul Farber directs Monument Lab, a nonprofit that studies and advises on monuments around the country. When it comes back to the art museum, to the base of the steps in 2006, I think it is seen more and more as an accepted monument in the city. The bureaucracy of the city is treating it as something that's going to stay. Once Rocky was installed, the city leaned fully into its status as a Philadelphia monument. Lights were added to illuminate the statue for night visitors. It was hoisted up onto a brand new foot and a half tall granite pedestal. This kind of publicly ratified monument is different from a statue that starts out as a monument. The art historian Alois Regal once talked about the distinction between what he called
并且正被当作纪念碑来对待。保罗·法伯指导“纪念碑实验室”，这是一个研究和提供全国各地纪念碑咨询的非营利组织。当它在2006年回到艺术博物馆、回到台阶底部时，我认为它越来越被视为这座城市中一个被接受的纪念碑。城市的官僚机构正把它当作将要留下来长久驻留的东西来对待。一旦洛奇安装完毕，这座城市就完全倾向于它作为费城纪念碑的地位。人们增加了灯光，以便夜间参观者也能看清这座雕像。它被吊装到了一个全新的一点五英尺高的花岗岩基座上。这种公开批准的纪念碑不同于一开始就是纪念碑的雕像。艺术史学家阿洛伊斯·里格尔曾谈到他所谓的
deliberate monuments and unintentional ones. The deliberate monuments are the dudes on horses, sculptures made explicitly to commemorate a person or an event. An unintentional monument is an object that becomes important to us, not for the reasons it was originally made. It becomes meaningful because of how we, the viewers, come to see it, like an ordinary house that later becomes a landmark or a museum. The Rocky statue had undergone this transformation. It had transcended the squabbles about art that initially surrounded it and arrived as a full-on monument.
刻意纪念碑和无意纪念碑之间的区别。刻意纪念碑是指骑马的人、为纪念某个人或某个事件而明确制作的雕塑。无意纪念碑是一个对我们变得重要的物体，它之所以重要，不是因为最初制造它的原因。它之所以变得有意义，是因为我们这些观看者如何看待它，就像后来成为地标或博物馆的普通房子一样。洛奇雕像经历了这种转变。它超越了最初围绕它的关于艺术的争端，作为一座成熟的纪念碑降临。
Up on its pedestal, looking over Philadelphia, it seemed like Rocky had at last found its permanent home. But then, about a decade into the statue's residence there, a tragedy more than 500 miles south of Philly would spark a reckoning about race and monuments around the country. And once again, Rocky was in the middle of a whole new controversy. More of that, after the break. By 2015, the Rocky statue had been standing beside the Philadelphia Museum of Art for nearly 10 years. It drew locals and tourists who posed and took pictures next to the bronze champ. It seemed like the statue could finally settle into its status as a true Philadelphia monument. But then, Rocky got swept up into a different fight.
它高高立在基座上，俯瞰着费城，似乎洛奇终于找到了它的永久家园。但随后，在雕像落户大约十年后，费城以南500多英里处发生的一场悲剧，引发了全国范围内关于种族和纪念碑的反思。洛奇再次处于全新争议的中心。休息之后，请听更多内容。到2015年，洛奇雕像已经在费城艺术博物馆旁矗立了近10年。它吸引了当地人和游客在青铜拳王旁边摆姿势拍照。这座雕像似乎终于可以确定其作为真正的费城纪念碑的地位了。但随后，洛奇被卷入了另一场争端。
It started in June 2015 when white supremacist Dylan Roof entered a black church in Charleston, South Carolina, and opened fire. Nine people were killed that day. Roof's plan was to start a race war. The mass shooting highlighted issues of white supremacist violence and domestic terrorism in the U.S. It also stirred up an ongoing conversation around racist symbols, especially monuments. Here's Paul Farber again from the Monument Lab. At that moment, there is a groundswell around rethinking the monuments that we have inherited and the symbols. We have a monument landscape that has elevated Confederates over civil rights.
这一切始于2015年6月，当时白人至上主义者迪伦·鲁夫进入南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的一座黑人教堂并开枪射击。那天有九人遇害。鲁夫的计划是挑起一场种族战争。这起大规模枪击事件凸显了美国的白人至上主义暴力和本土恐怖主义问题。它还引发了围绕种族主义符号、尤其是纪念碑的持续讨论。再次请出纪念碑实验室的保罗·法伯。“在那一刻，出现了一股重新思考我们继承的纪念碑和符号的浪潮。我们的纪念碑景观将南方邦联置于民权运动之上。”
Around the country, people began questioning flags and statues representing America's racist history. Eventually, that reckoning came to Philly. The spotlight fell on a few monuments in particular, including several Christopher Columbus statues, also a statue of former mayor Frank Rizzo, known for violent policing in black communities and racially inflammatory rhetoric. And when Paul's organization, Monument Lab, asked Philadelphians about what kinds of monuments they would build to reflect their city's visions and values, he heard questions about whether Rocky was a good monument for Philly. At that point, like, Rocky isn't in the spotlight in the heat of a reckoning about monuments,
在全国各地，人们开始质疑代表美国种族主义历史的旗帜和雕像。最终，这种清算降临到了费城。聚光灯落在了几座特定的纪念碑上，包括几座克里斯托弗·哥伦布雕像，以及前市长弗兰克·里佐的雕像——里佐因在黑人社区采取暴力执法和具有种族煽动性的言论而闻名。当保罗的组织“纪念碑实验室”询问费城人他们会建造什么样的纪念碑来反映他们城市的愿景和价值观时，他听到了关于洛奇是否是费城好纪念碑的性质的疑问。在那时，就像，洛奇并没有成为纪念碑清算热潮的焦点，
but the murmurs are there. Some of those murmurs went like this. Rocky's cool, but Philly is a city with a real history of boxing. And unlike the fictional Italian stallion, most of those real boxers were black, including Joe Frazier, the one-time heavyweight champion and first to defeat Muhammad Ali in a fight that over 300 million people watch. Frazier becomes a kind of beloved hometown hero in Philadelphia. You know, you don't have Rocky Balboa without Joe Frasier.
但细语已经存在。其中一些议论是这样的：洛奇很酷，但费城是一座拥有真正拳击历史的城市。与虚构的意大利种马不同，大多数真正的拳击手都是黑人，包括乔·弗雷泽，这位前重量级冠军，也是第一位在一场有3.05亿多人观看的比赛中击败穆罕默德·阿里的人。弗雷泽在费城成了一种深受爱戴的家乡英雄。你知道的，没有乔·弗雷泽，就不会有洛奇·巴尔博亚。
Paul's referring to the fact the most famous parts of the training montage in the first Rocky movie, running up the museum's steps and punching raw meat, those were actually taken from Frazier's real workout routines. Fraser did get a statue in 2015, but for a lot of Philadelphians, the 12-foot bronze likeness fell short of a fair tribute to a real-life boxing legend, especially compared to the love Rocky it received. We heard that Joe Frazier wasn't getting his due, that there was an opportunity to do right by his legacy.
保罗指的是这样一个事实：第一部《洛奇》电影中训练蒙太奇最著名的部分——跑上博物馆台阶和击打生肉——实际上是取自弗雷泽真实的训练日常。弗雷泽确实在2015年有了一座雕像，但对许多费城人来说，这座12英尺高的青铜塑像远未能对现实生活中的拳击传奇人物给予公平的致敬，特别是与洛奇所受到的喜爱相比。我们听说乔·弗雷泽没有得到应有的待遇，存在着一个为他的传奇做对的机会。
His image is not emblazoned on tour buses, and the steps that he ran up are called the Rocky steps. That imbalance and the question it raised around race were soon brought into even sharper focus. In the summer of 2020, after the murder of George Floyd, the ongoing fight over America's monuments heated up once again. Ordinary citizens toppled statues depicting historical figures associated with racist ideas. Five days after Floyd was killed, someone set fire to the Rizzo statue. In Marconi Plaza, groups of mostly white residents armed with clubs and guns surrounded a Columbus statue to guard it from being torn down.
他的形象没有印在旅游巴士上，而他跑过的台阶却被称为洛奇台阶。这种失衡以及它引发的有关种族的疑问很快被推到了更加鲜明的焦点上。在2020年夏天，在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后，关于美国纪念碑的持续斗争再次白热化。普通公民推翻了描绘与种族主义思想相关的历史人物的雕像。弗洛伊德被杀五天后，有人放火烧了里佐雕像。在马可尼广场，主要由手持棍棒和枪支的白人居民组成的群体包围了一座哥伦布雕像，以防其被拆除。
As for Rocky, now that his statue was considered a monument, it would have to face the same scrutiny as these other statues. Here was a tribute to a fictional white movie character who many felt had stolen the spotlight from a real hometown black boxing champion. Surely that meant Rocky's days were numbered. But that's not how things played out. Philly's largest Black Lives Matter demonstrations kicked off every day.
至于洛奇，既然他的雕像被认为是一座纪念碑，它就必须面对与这些其他雕像相同的审视。这里是对一个虚构的白人电影角色的致敬，许多人认为他抢走了现实生活中黑人拳击冠军的风头。这当然意味着洛奇的日子不多了。但事情的发展并非如此。费城最大的“黑人的命也是命”示威活动每天都在
day at the art museum steps. Thousands of protesters gathered right next to the Rocky statue. And instead of being torn down or moved somewhere else, Rocky was incorporated into the rallies. So like, where's Rocky in all of this? Someone has put a sign on Rocky that reads, no justice, no peace. Not only did Rocky get a role in the Black Lives Matter protests, but people started using him for other causes, putting all sorts of stuff. on his bronze body.
艺术博物馆台阶上拉开帷幕。成千上万的抗议者聚集在洛奇雕像旁边。洛奇不仅没有被拆除或搬到别处，反而被纳入了集会之中。那么，洛奇在这其中扮演什么角色呢？有人在洛奇身上挂了一个标语，上面写着：没有正义，就没有和平。洛奇不仅在“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动中扮演了角色，人们还开始将他用于其他事业，在他的青铜机体上挂上各种各样的东西。
You have a face mask in the early days of the lockdown. You have a Ukrainian flag. When the Eagles' famed defensive end, Brandon Graham, retires, he puts his cleats on Rocky. Rocky became this container for the city's complicated
在封锁的早期，你有一个口罩。你有一面乌克兰国旗。当老鹰队的著名防守端锋布兰登·格雷厄姆退役时，他把自己的球鞋挂在了洛奇身上。洛奇成了这座城市复杂且
and sometimes contradictory emotions. Paul saw this on a day early in the pandemic when he looked at the line of people waiting to take pictures with the statue. So there's a black family and as they're posing for a photo, everyone holds up the black power fist of solidarity.
有时相互矛盾的情绪的容器。保罗在疫情初期的一天看到了这一幕，当时他看着排队等待与雕像合影的人群。所以有一个黑人家庭，当他们摆姿势拍照时，每个人都高举着声援的黑人力量拳头。
And three or four people later, there's like a group of white guys, I think they were in their early 20s, hold up a white power sign. So these two things are happening almost together, but not confrontationally? Yeah, that's right. The rocky statue could hold all of this.
三四个人之后，有一群白人小伙子，我想他们大概二十岁出头，举起了一个白人至上主义的手势。所以这两件事几乎是一起发生，但不是对抗性的？是的，没错。洛奇雕像能够承载所有这一切。
Whether you liked it or hated it, thought it was beautiful or ugly, agreed with the person next to you in line, or found their views apporrent, The statue had become linked to the whole city. It was like a song everyone in Philly knew, and people could remix it in lots of ways so that it meant something just for them.
无论你喜欢它还是讨厌它，认为它是美的还是丑的，同意排在你旁边的人的观点，还是觉得他们的观点令人反感，这座雕像已经与整座城市联系在了一起。这就像费城每个人都知道的一首歌，人们可以用很多方式对其进行重新混音，使其对他们自己具有特殊的意义。
In 2020, the Frank Rizzo statue got moved into storage. The Columbus statue had a plywood box placed over it while the city decided what to do with it. But Rocky? His statue has only gotten more popular. Paul Farber guests curated a show about box. at the Philadelphia Museum of Art. And what did the exhibition feature?
2020年，弗兰克·里佐雕像被移入仓库。哥伦布雕像则被罩上了一个胶合板箱，而市政府则在决定拿它怎么办。但是洛奇呢？他的雕像只变得更受欢迎了。保罗·法伯曾担任费城艺术博物馆一个关于拳击的展览的客座策展人。展览展出了什么？
None other than the statue that had been repeatedly kicked off its steps. Paul had moved it from the bottom of the steps to inside the museum for the show. Once that was over, Rocky moved again back outside. And this time, it was right where Stallone had always wanted it at the top of the museum steps, permanently, at least for now. Read the Philly Inquirer any week, and you'll see there's still deep disagreement about whether this is the right place for it. Some people think the statue has found its rightful home. Others hate that it clogs up the museum plaza, with vendors selling Rocky-related chotchkes. And others are just tired of talking about it.
正是这座曾多次被赶下台阶的雕像。保罗为了这个展览，将其从台阶底部移到了博物馆内部。展览结束后，洛奇又被搬回了室外。这一次，它正好位于史泰龙一直希望它在的地方——博物馆台阶的顶端，永久地，至少目前是这样。每周随便翻看《费城问询报》，你都会发现，对于这是否是它的正确位置，仍然存在着深刻的分歧。有些人认为这座雕像找到了它应有的家。另一些人则讨厌它堵塞了博物馆广场，还有小贩在兜售与洛奇相关的廉价纪念品。还有人只是厌倦了谈论它。
In an additional move that some see as a tribute and others as a consolation prize, Joe Fraser's statue has been moved to Rocky's old spot. at the bottom of the museum steps and a little to the side. When this started, there was a sense that it was Rocky fighting to get to the top of the museum steps. And there were people against that. So, like, did Rocky win? I don't think that there is a simple winner. Let the never-ending Rocky series show us that what we're seeing right now is just another chapter in a story that will keep unfolding.
在另一个被一些人视为致敬、被另一些人视为安慰奖的举动中，乔·弗雷泽的雕像被移到了洛奇以前的位置——艺术博物馆台阶的底部并稍微偏侧一点。这一切刚开始时，有一种感觉，那是洛奇在争取登上博物馆台阶的顶端。并且有人反对这一点。那么，就像，洛奇赢了吗？我不认为有一个简单的赢家。永无止境的《洛奇》系列向我们表明，我们现在看到的只是一个将继续展开的故事的又一个章节。
Monuments are not conclusions. They're not periods at the end of a sentence. Nothing is forever. No monument is permanent. Every champion throws a last punch. Even Rocky had to hang up his gloves eventually. It's true. Nothing in this world lasts forever.
纪念碑不是结论。它们不是句号。没有什么东西是永远的。没有一座纪念碑是永久的。每个拳击冠军都会打出最后一拳。甚至连洛奇最终也必须挂起他的手套。确实如此。这世上没有什么东西是永恒的。
Except maybe the sequels. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Justin Crayman, produced and edited by Christopher Johnson, Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and Paul Vitekiss. Fact-checking by Graham Hesia. Special thanks this week to Michael Vitez, David Brownlee, and Peter C. Sutton. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kirk Colestead is the digital director.
也许续集除外。99%隐形本周由贾斯汀·克莱默报道，克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作和剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔和保罗·维泰基斯创作。事实核查由格雷姆·赫西亚完成。本周特别鸣谢迈克尔·维泰茨、大卫·布朗利和彼得·C·萨顿。凯茜·2是我们的执行制作人。柯克·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lachamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。其余团队成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、维维安·莱、拉查马多恩、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。99%隐形标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。我们是天狼星XM播客家族的一员，现在总部设在北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼内，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心北部。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有一个指向该服务器以及99PI每一期过往剧集的链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。